[Musique]
après droite quand
mêmeuxour
Dr on les sentir les tu crois
hayio un momento RA laista
eh
[Musique]
recibido de ha POS mismo
ist
les la qui
avance ça c'est ton écran avec
le ve
[Musique]
dire trs
trèss
contaoendo
moral8
matinorisation gros qui
travaill laisse
[Musique]
tomber même un truc pour les
corrid
quiintéresse non c'est délirant quand
même c'est hallucinant ah ouaisou
alors est-ce qu'elle fait comme de la
lave est-ce que ça fait ça ton écran
maintenant mais quand c'est un peu plus
serré attends bouge pas non non non mais
c'est mettre sur les volcans on pas fait
de volcan ontion donc
RAR
[Musique]
FO
très
doucement ça sur comm ça voilà ça c'est
bien un peu très très très très
doucement va tout
[Musique]
doucement long plan long plan long plan
continue c'est sublime ça c'est
vachement
[Musique]
beau
je parle pas ça je te parle de regarde
la piste là regarde on est dans l'axe
non non mais je te parle avant ok c'est
bon mais je ve dire pasentrer dans dans
le dans le dans la zone tu peux y aller
quoi on était dans la zone depuis un
super
moment la zone elle est à la moitié des
ser d'accord mais est pas tu vois on est
pas je t' guueule pas là c'est qu'on est
pas non plus à faire des trucs dangereux
quoi tu c'est pas une question de
dangereux ou pas c'est une question moi
je suis désolé quoi j'ai une licence
c'est bon c'est le seul truc que je sais
faire voilà j'ai si j'ai si je la perd
je peux plus ouais ok ben ouais il y a
je suis désolé quoi je t gueule pas là
non non moi non plus mais bon voilà ça
me gaffe quoi fais des efforts et tout
ATT arrête arrête je
[Musique]
demand tranqu l'heure maintenant pardon
excuse-moi non mais j'ai pas envie de
m'ueer